[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is what they call our one family
you goddamn right
father
I just don't like
are you expecting from daddy leader
justice gonna spank your butt spanked
you under par quite frankly at first I
didn't give a damn but because of you I
know it's important I know what I need
to do
good morning everyone welcome to
GameSpot live welcome back today I'm
here with Alessandro and we are gonna be
playing Devil May Cry 3 which was just
released for the Nintendo switch yes
yesterday saundra how you doing man good
of course yes you might need to speak up
in that mic it's kind of a low one ok
but we'll switch over here we got a few
we got a few minutes to just talk about
the game and apparently this port has
some tricks up its sleeve it's got some
special features you want to talk to
those sure surprisingly this is the
definitive version
yeah for a while we're playing the
special edition that's right
but this version the swish release is
cool yeah that's great news that's nice
that the the switch is getting some love
you might be an older title like not be
mc5 or anything but like everyone loves
dmc3 right easily I guess one of the
more fan favorite games of the series
this is also the game that you know put
the series back on track after the very
the black sheep of the series I guess to
put it lightly of Doublemint cry - right
yeah I know it's a what this version
adds in particular is that it puts in
style switching which is a check see if
that's better chat let me know if you
guys can hear Alessandro clearly hello
can you hear me yeah okay yeah the
switch version of Devil May Cry 3 adds
in style switching which is a sort of a
an innovation that came with a
development cry 4 which came out in 2008
and that's very interesting for this
game because uh initially you can only
switch styles at a put in like actual
menus like you know when you're
customizing your character and uh you're
very much locked in whichever style you
chose right so now you can just do it on
the fly absolutely and that creates
really interesting possibilities in
combat and uh in the hands of like a
high level player this completely
changes the game I would classify you as
a high level player I think you know
your way around a DMC game no I mean I
love this series a lot I actually wrote
the history of devil McRae you see we
got the right guy on stream today the
video that went up last year which it
was fantastic
Gianluca cut that video that's right a
great job
ok you guys check that off you guys love
DMC like Alessandro I didn't know you
rode that I thought John Luke did that's
very cool no yeah we worked on it
together by I wrote the script and he's
the one that sort of pieced it together
sure he's a great editor yeah he put it
all together
ya know also another thing that this
adds is a this particular edition of
DOMA Cry 3 is that it adds in coop for
bloody that's huge
that's what's interesting is that this
game you know came out 15 years ago yet
it got co-opted bloody Palace ahead of
Devil May Cry 5 which is Wow which came
before okay which came out last year
which is like the minutest Devil May Cry
game yet right you know this game that
came out 15 years ago got a more you
know the thing that people want like
member think that the new sort of
feature that a lot of Devil May Cry fans
want sure well what is that when you
described the coop what did you say
blood palace is le palace bloody palace
is basically like a gauntlet like you
know a hundred floors okay okay I
thought we I thought the option was
there to co-opt the whole campaign no no
no okay it's very much that as it was
but but uh you're actually gonna be
helping me fight through a bloody pile
I'm with it we have a second joy con set
up here just for me Alessandro's I'm the
main one there and just a few minutes
we'll get started but we just wanted to
talk about oops sorry
yeah co-op is actually just local co-op
only there's no online unfortunately so
it's okay it's just couch co-op that's
fine it's still a good start and you
know the fact that we're getting any
special features for this port at all is
pretty special I'm gonna whoops I'm
gonna link the article our latest
article on gamespot.com
about the some of the updates that
Alessandra and I are talking about feel
free to click and check there's quite a
few articles about you can see this port
specifically that's they're doing so
well with like fanfare and like a lot of
stuff like throwback stuff and they're
paying attention to like their older
titles a little more lately I mean
Resident Evil of course but like even
things outside of that like this like
this this special edition sounds pretty
special
I mean poor choice of words but I think
you know what I mean this thing it's it
is the the actual special edition from
that was released in 2006 but it's been
greatly enhanced and this is honest they
should rename this as mm acquire three
definitive definitive right or what is
it a XD what do they do they are so many
nicknames for Cooper Street
super super double may cry 3 yes and
Knuckles right
[Laughter]
ya know this is a yeah should we just
jump in there sure man before we begin
though yes of all the Devil May Cry
games which one's your favorite
hmm have you played them all most I
played all of them all of them I fall
aid bill my cry too like to completion
both with both characters so cool yeah I
actually still have a lot of attachment
to the original Devil May Cry oh cool
okay
nothing wrong with that yeah no I mean
it just has a particular that's very
different from the other games like you
know as the other game sort of like
found it like yet its identity that what
the series was all about yeah but I also
really admire ninja theory as a reboot
attempted reboot sure DMC Devil May Cry
um I actually think the definitive
edition that they released about Wow
almost five years ago now actually was
pretty fantastic and it is easily among
the top double May Cry games of the
franchise but it's great but DMC 5 was
also fantastic and which came out last
year we had a lot of hyper on that in
the office overall I think it was just a
very good entry I need to get on the DMC
train myself surprise I know I know
especially cuz like when you were saying
like um
DMC like hadn't found his voice yet
really and kind of liked the first one
because it was remember how it was like
supposed to be like a sort of spin-off
or like next iteration Resident Evil and
it was it was like it's it still became
its own new thing but then like it's
streamlined the process you're saying
around to like part 2 were like it
really found its own voice and I'm not a
spinoff of Resident Evil yeah so I'm
glad I'm glad you like - it's a special
game now we're all ready for part three
are you ready yeah we have 30 seconds
left that's fine let's just jump into it
folks I know you're all here to see this
game picture-in-picture BAM there we are
and yeah actually we can just look at
that gold you already got some gold well
actually just to explain gold is
actually a sort of a particular mode
like for like sort of game you want to
play like a yellow is the initial like
sort of traditional original devil
right like okay gold is like add
basically adds in like sort of like
wives okay I thought that was a ranking
like you did you did gold on this
playthrough already that's where the
sort of the ranking system comes in with
yes oh right they have over the top
ranking like cool awesome as this and
that your if you like rankings then you
need to play that way Kroy sounds like
it's become a meme but the new thing
that you can say that I'm sure a lot of
longtime fans will see is that they've
added this new thing called freestyle
right first the mode you were talking
yes a freestyle is the thing that's very
different with this addition it adds
once you select freestyle versus the
original edition so if you want to just
stick with what Devil May Cry 3 was you
sure I can do that
it's classic yeah so freestyle adds in
the style switching and the sort of
expanded weapon swapping I can't wait to
see now look like it's just now that
it's on the fly it's gonna be so
seamless I hope and you've had some
hands on this it came out yesterday
right this one yeah we've had this for
like almost a week now oh sweet but yeah
I've been it just officially came out so
excellent yeah and how is it ported on
to the switch like are we getting
graphical updates or like is it like
it's pretty much similar to what it was
on the recent ports with the you know
kiss 4 and Xbox I see okay you just
crank this up a little bit for our okay
we got to do it I mean that many
numbered sequels one of them's got to be
predator out that will make right you
turned out really yeah Resident Evil do
that to remember they went back to zero
and what's interesting about this game
is that
at this point where the only cry
franchise was like storytelling well
interesting like they saved that good
storytelling for the prequels this this
game is very much a story about two
brothers who just don't really get all
right
eventually no things happen and they
have together here we go
that's them right there assume yep you
know I'm definitely aware of the series
you can't you can't ignore this series
in the gaming community I was telling
Alessandro if you're just tuning in that
I haven't played this yet but I have the
same problem with multiple series like I
want to start from one I want to start
from beginning and I just don't have
that kind of time to jump from from one
to five you know what I mean but these
games have always looked really cool
really flashy and memed out like of
course like the whole which one was it
where you got like the pizza-delivery
intro dude and he's like wearing no
shirt this is the one yeah awesome
great we're gonna jump into it oh no
awesome
even yeah even I know that opening
pretty well like one that sort of like
that trailer that first trailer like
showing that
what is going on because it wasn't like
two or one it sounded look like like it
wasn't taking itself that seriously in a
good way like here is that one maker I
was always very much about like cheesy
sort of Hollywood act I love that I
cannot believe I have not played this
and so glad you're here oh oh yeah I
will try to do my best once the action
starts popping off so I know I know
it'll be just fine
there it is oh my god I need to answer
my phone like this what's interesting
about the style of this game is a
director still might cry three four and
five
specifically refers to the stylist
Chunin who needs a me basically like
over the top I want to be like cool
style
have you seen like oh yeah somebody been
same energy okay
oh that's cool because I'm getting TMNT
vibes eat yeah he's like the fit turtle
he's like kind of cocky and like a
little borderline annoying but like it's
all part of his Dante although I don't
think there were any Renaissance
painters named doctor close enough right
well there it is Chad how are we doing I
barely I've barely talked to you this
morning I've been chatting with
Alessandra how we doing
you guys gonna pick this up for the
switch let me know oh he saved the pizza
I love this guy more and more every
second oh my god for sure oh yeah he's
fine so cocky I mean I'm ray I already
agree with you since the opening shot
where he kicked the phone flipped it
like matrix-style was like sorry we're
not open for business and he still has
no shirt on there it is let's rock oh my
god oh it doesn't work Oh
let's rock okay now we officially can
kick some ass
oh yes bring him back the pizza now when
did this originally come out that you
say 2005 the original okay cool
yeah
[Music]
is very difficult they actually made the
game harder why do they do that feel
like the Japanese releases of most of
these games are always easier than the
the re-release American version they
always do that
okay so the normal mode in that was
great yeah the normal mode and basically
in the US release of don't like grocery
the original one was actually the
Japanese card mode I knew it
you know what Resident Evil 2 had the
same situation maybe it's just a Capcom
thing I don't know but they address that
with a special Egyptian by adding the
golden yellow okay yeah all right let's
just jump into it y'all Oh looks pretty
good oh yeah the cutscene was a little
scrambled but this looks a lot better
yeah the game run
yeah you can only update those so much
Chris W I turned down the game volume
for you bro
hopefully this works hopefully we're
sounding good let me know keep up those
comments appreciate those always oh my
god where's the pizza I need to know
[Laughter]
this was around the time like god of war
was hot too like this is just like a
time stamp of that era I think so cool
what a special year thanks I was all
over that game me maybe that's why I
didn't pick up this series well you know
it this was already well into this is
part three already here my god war one
came out in 2005
nice dude I can't touch you maybe I
should have kept my big yapper shut
Prakash yep must save the pizza welcome
back Akash Brendan Menendez what's going
on man he says now I want to play DMC
five you do you man this game just
dropped this dmc3 of course but it just
dropped them a switch yesterday with
quite a lot of special features so if
you like what you're seeing you too can
be plain but DMC 5 yeah different D
sighs I'm sure Alessandro oh yeah but a
fun game nonetheless I've heard can we
get a close-up of his abs still again
he's still not wearing a shirt we're all
ok with this though look there's a
bottle of Jack on the ground those
swords are pretty cool the swords
actually talk really yes
Wow yeah I for those of you who are just
tuning in
Alessandro knows what he's talking about
and I know crap about this I know like
vaguely about this series and Dante of
course and this whole this game
specifically we went over the intro and
the pizza fling in phone call alright
this guy's got to go there you go he
ruined the pizza that's a good question
what's the best DMC game for newcomers
cuz I myself and in that pool actually
you just jump straight into DMC 5 5
that's cool they do a good job of like
sort of like presenting the story
what happens in a previous entry so
that's good
that's your first entry in the series
and you nice ok good
sounds like five is an approachable game
for being a fifth installment that's
great
but if you want to you know go like in
the proper route like you know play the
original games first then you can
download
oh cool does that like a pack are they
just each individual release well I'm a
switch release their individual releases
but uh oh ps4 and Xbox one they're say
oh I love that I love collections like
that it's perfect for me to jump into
yes also devil may cry for and DMC
definitive edition are also standalone
awesome
got some nice ranks there yeah not bad
not bad I'm gonna move over the chat to
this window also so I can keep up with
y'all the chat window is a little too
far for me so we keep up here there we
go - BAM
Tony in the chat says best looking port
since The Witcher 3 I am impressed mr.
Vinh says number one is a little dated
but the atmosphere is still top-notch he
agrees great burritos dead welcome back
this is Alessandro yeah we should keep a
little nametags the whole time but this
is all Sandro DMC God and editor Akash
yeah I love that song too Alejandro by
lady gaga
this is Alessandro Alessandro Alessandro
yeah good song though
crazy I love those rankings up top
that's the part of the fun all right
Oh Alessandra do you know how much this
this port is for the switch 24 Nintendo
is always like they're doing a great job
lately of bringing titles that weren't
originally on their Hardware over to the
switch especially even as far back as
you know things like Wolfenstein like
things that they never even considered
before doom everything by Bethesda it's
all coming to the switch but more and
more like things like this this was a
PlayStation exclusive back in the day
wasn't it it was that's so cool
oh nice okay now switch is getting some
love
the expanded okay right there that
little key on the right there Oh Oh
what's so seamless now you have the
whole wheel that's sick and his
swordmaster up there on the top left
like your fighting style
oh nice is it like a melee base but with
the Dodge okay this is so sick it looks
like this is how it was originally
intended like it just it looks is so
smooth that's what I'm saying this looks
like this is the definitive core for
sure
oh yeah back in the day huh this game is
so over the top there we go we got a
who's that in the chat oh maybe closest
possible the closer the better that
might be that better for a year but I do
try to keep quiet most of the time I
hope they don't just mean the volume if
Alessandra's volume is low let me know
because we can just actually I can't
turn it up much more that's it it's
maxed out how's this can you hear me
let us know chat ooh
Virgil is better than Dante mmm your
thoughts I mean I prefer Dante's
versatility over Virgil and also summon
sword abilities what you're gonna we're
gonna see here are we're gonna play in
co-op mode let's go through one more
level than we can oh yeah will you take
your time with this nothing I mean we
can just do this for a whole stream but
we do want to show off some co-op play
Chris double yeah I think your mic is
low it's it is turned up all the way
I'll senator we just need your outdoor
voice man all right out door yeah Bob
Jones even knows that left mic is always
a little low we gotta look into that
because it's maxed out here on the board
we have the same mic but I don't know
what's going on skyrim on the switch see
I'm going back to Tony's comment about
all these ports that are making their
way over to the switch it's very nice to
see for people who just have never
played before myself included for some
of these
nice job Ching clear could have been
better could have been better feel like
two like platinum this game do you have
to get s rankings in every mission for
every thing ever or do you have a super
dude it sounds like I don't know it
sound like a grind to complete this game
like to the max Mikasa says I actually
had to draw out some maps for certain
sections of the game is to get puzzling
laters a little hard to navigate big
maps it does like actually sort of hang
on to some of the its roots were from
the Resident Evil series where you
actually have to explore like a certain
like items that you need to bring from
one area to the next
that is like resident evil like the
police station and all the keys and all
that stuff is scattered everywhere the
later games like after three would like
more that's fine that's fine I guess
come to know and you sort of bond with
sure you know you're you get to connect
with in some way so you know it is
interesting seeing like you know so it's
early roots with her
a very clear resolutely well that's cool
I mean it's nice that it had a little
bit of everything it sounds like this
series is always changing and evolving
but now it's kind of found its voice
over the years the car said oh my god
the memories my friend this is available
now on the Nintendo switch this is a
special edition of DMC three got co-op
it's got a different what was it
freestyle like different fighting modes
you can equip on the on salvaging style
switching back to the expanded weapon
swapping yes which is really cool
instead of being able to only switch
between two weapons you got a whole
wheel of all of your weapons
alessandra here is demonstrating it
wonderfully
Brandon Hernandez says I use my switch
more than my ps4 now boy I mean like I
was saying we were singing its praises
for all the ports and original games
it's getting yeah the switches become a
real powerhouse it is I mean The Witcher
that's like the wit that's incredible
and achievement a great thing note is
that this is the number three yeah this
is mission three that's a recurring gag
for every level in this game where
you'll actually see the number before
like the cutscene before the actual
level that was funny and like there's
one point where like seven okay
Zach yes this version that was just
released yesterday for the switch has
some co-op it's not for the campaign but
it's like how did you describe it
already with bloody palace mode in
particular which is a gauntlet right
we will be demonstrating that little
later Zach also says there are too many
games coming out bro that's why this is
the perfect gay because Alessandra was
here and I couldn't agree with you more
like there's a lot to be played right
now I have not gotten into this series
but I think it's about time this is a
good excuse
Tony says some more cross platforming
between the switch and PC would be nice
I agreed nothing wrong with any cross
platforming as long as it can be
technically pulled off then I have no
problems I would love to see more of
that myself APEC still doesn't have it
black star
this is running really smoothly chat let
me know which DMC games have you played
what's your favorite who's your favorite
character show some love friend that's
in the chat with us here muck amuck says
I think they missed an opportunity to
call it this the SS s special edition
[Laughter]
that's like the highest ever write the
maxed out ranking you can get in this
game or was it like a triple five triple
s that's it oh my god that's so extra
but I love it there we go that's some
some quick weapon swapping got the whole
wheel there
was team c1 have reported to the switch
yes
yep that's so DMC one DMC - I'm
surprised they did it but they did it
DMC - and of course that will make y3 I
agree and if they can do this I can
probably do four
whoa I mean did for come out for the
next generation like the ps3 days yes
okay Ben djenka trolling in the chat
says my favorite DMC game is Bayonetta 2
you know whether right
no wonder no wonder it's got that same
energy it does there's a lot of
references to the DOMA cry series in
nation
honestly like if they make a cross over
it yeah whenever they're in the same
universe probably not stamping in the
chat says GMC one will always have a
special place in my heart three is
probably the best though can't be
welcome to a chat thank you for sharing
mr. Vinh said I played three four and
five a bit of reboot beam three about
like eight times that's nice so three is
a fan favorite here it seems today other
mine we got we got a tracks in the chat
saying Dan c2 is the best of course
got a spin around the pole Oh what is he
talking about
can you pole dance as Dante okay that
was fun that was exactly what I wanted
did we get anything any sexier and be
out of character he just did a little
woman
this is great yeah
oh also uh speaking of Bayonetta the
sort of ps4 and Xbox one edition just
came out oh really yeah we played it uh
I think I'm Monday or Tuesday I think
Persia was here holding it down yeah
that's been their 10-year anniversary I
marked that on my calendar so we can
play on stream i'm glad persia got to it
there we go
what are those little faces called a
look so these are red orbs red orbs okay
basically the currency oh yeah little by
little I'm picking up on it for those of
you who don't know in chat or just
tuning in I haven't played these I
definitely am aware of these especially
part three because of that meme tastic
intro that have not played one it's
maybe my chance like sort of enhanced
like enhance my current abilities while
also adding in new ones
cool hair hike which is the double Joe
love it
I think it might have been an
opportunity right here to remake these
menus but they just kept them in 4:3 and
left it alone that's fine yeah okay is
exactly how it was it looked better on a
CRT classics here right oh yeah sweet
John Doe ask what's better the switch or
the switch light that's a big that's a
big like depends sort of answer because
switch light you don't have access to
play on your TV so if you want to play
things on your TV go for the original
switch switch light is 100% portable
actually oh go for a dude all right we
will I will talk with chat and we will
wait before this boss fight it's
freaking Alessandro out Chad how we
doing Gabriel says damn I remember how
good DMC soundtrack DMC's 3 soundtrack
is probably the best so far this whole
this whole experience has been great I
need to definitely jumped into the DMC
series myself I'm lacking but like I was
telling Alessandro you know I wanted to
play one and two and three I wanted to
do him in order because although he told
me five is an approachable one to just
jump into so I think I might I might
start with five although I don't know
we'll see here I'm having a good time
watching him play three three looks
really good especially on the switch I'm
surprised how smooth it's running easy
selectable stage
yeah John Doe I would I personally like
like it's it's unpopular around here but
I like to play mice which docked so I
like to play on the big screen whenever
possible I usually play that thing at
home and I never take it with me
anywhere so it's perfect for me but if
you're always on the go or just you know
it while you're commuting or anything
like that the switch light is best and I
think it's a little cheaper might want
to look into that for you
ghost Walker game says this game is
godlike man I want that feeling I'm not
there yet
Alessandro has convinced me otherwise I
just haven't played this for myself but
I'm watching him play today and it's
going really well
how's last week I forgot about what do
you guys think about the reboot Oh
that'd be a good question for all of
Sandro I am in the dark about it but he
will have stuff to talk about when it
comes to that he played them all
Alejandra I asked him right before the
stream started actually during the
stream have you played all of them and
he was like yep I played every single
one ah then says I'm gonna start the
series with DMC 5 on ps4 um I think I
might do the same either one or five
because Alessandra told me five was just
fine to start with sorry we are waiting
for Alessandro he just needed a bathroom
break he'll be right back and I do not
want he's about to start a boss fight so
I'm not gonna f with this controller
Mecosta says I would recommend going
from five three one four that's all out
of order and only two if you're curious
skip Ninja Theory we'll skip the Ninja
Theory one who appreciate the advice I
definitely I think I might start with
five
he's back ladies and gentlemen not
everyone boss if I oh no big deal I was
just chatting with them we got some
advice for how to how I should start the
series a lot of people are saying 5 is a
good place to start just like you
recommend you one person though said
skip the Ninja Theory reboot it's got a
lot of I feel like it's gotten a
negative reputation like unfortunately
um when it was revealed they did it on
the wrong foot and I think a lot of
people didn't sort of that's how I take
to it but the game I feel is a really
good it's a remake of the first one like
the Ninja Theory one or it's a reboot
just the whole reboot oh ok ok
Wow here we go
oh no wonder someone the chat was like
Cerberus like oh just like some Harry
Potter
Hercules [ __ ] right here you actually
saw me using I did yeah
defeat the bosses that will make for a
game you actually oh that's sick oh
that's so cool it's like a keyblade you
get from their world always talking
smack
we got another suggestion to skip part
two it's like go for three one four and
five skip to you guys fine do doesn't
exist here if you want to just play just
to see what it was like then go ahead
someone said if you're curious only play
to like the plot whatever happened the
two does not
is it like not even officially canon
anymore it is actually they they've
largely ignored it when this game
but
start to acknowledge it again that's
good they stuck to their guns they
acknowledge their seemingly mistakes got
another suggestion for the time line
three one two four five that's all over
the map
phillipe says this OST is much better
than the version legacy much better than
the version of King Cerberus yes I'm
thinking to the soundtrack so far like
entirely it's perfect for this kind of
game just like rock and like metal fast
paced all that stuff he's like stuck to
the wall isn't he he's like change leave
now mortal
mr. ben says the modifiers in the
definitive edition makes the game so
much better
Alessandro agrees isn't the first one Oh
actually
that basically altered like I see like a
certain enemies to be damage ring oh boy
yeah that sounds harder actually came
from the modern
that's cool
yeah that's actually
all getting a lot of advice from the
chat about how to go about playing this
Anderson loves this song said this song
is awesome got him
almost almost you break his head off I
guess I missed oh yeah Oh chopper oh
[ __ ] he's heating up
so now this has been switched this has
been ported over to the switch with a
bunch of new features you can change
your fighting style and you have the
option to click through any of the
weapons you want to select them on the
fighter
not just to anyone believe dig in the
song oh there we go
so now do you think Alessandro it'll be
harder to play the original vanilla
version of this without all the
switching and changes now we're spoiled
I'm gonna play this version and no
nothing else
Chris W says DMC de also has a proper
lock on what's the e definitive edition
okay cool cool
the original actually didn't include a
lock on system Oh bummer but um the
combat system they made actually worked
pretty well okay it was more so about
just swap trying to jump between
different okay you know what God award
didn't have lock on right away did know
using wale around everything and just
kill whoever gets in front of you
well maybe not necessary but it's nice
to have that option I guess with the
Ninja Theory version ghost Walker says
dmc3 has the best music hands-down
that was the flashiest way to introduce
your new weapon yeah by the way it looks
sick it's like a three-headed nunchuck
yeah just like he said I just heard that
was reading the chat I heard of whaling
eat your heart out Michelangelo now is
this weapon actually dope or is it just
like oh that's cool
flexing ones that talk okay okay
cuz when you actually get them for the
first time I guess I missed that
oh no he gets them does he get him in
the previous game no did he get them in
the beginning that's my favorite part
he just my god what is this metal gear
and the matrix remember that the Twin
Snakes oh my god this is exactly what
saw the same thing and then you shot it
back at the hind d that was great yeah I
definitely need more of this I got to
start playing I hope in like the later
games they don't calm him down because
that energy is just
Oh actually that was one of the reasons
why I think
they'll make fried to particulars but
they made them they made them much more
still way oh I can't do that as much
more reserved the only occasionally said
like one-liner
no this dude is dancing like he still
doesn't really have a proper shirt
yelling I don't know it's a look I guess
oh yeah
what does maybe that like holds the
swords on his back but it's like it's a
bell yeah but I don't I don't know it's
fashion and I don't understand it all
right yeah DBS APRI DBS and the chat
appreciated that rocket riding scene
that was so dope I've slept on this
series it sounds like you're really
enjoying yourself
I'm not playing it's also actually you
know maybe it's time for you right now
me okay I mean if you're cool with the I
don't know I don't want to ruin your
record here you're not no oh yeah okay
lady Palace is the new co-op mode yes so
you can do what's interesting is that
they've unlocked bloody palace from a
start so you can take your current
progress
well I'm mission 9 right now and I've
got everything up until that point like
all the weapons and what my up character
like health upgrades and stuff at that
point and bring it into bleh palace of
sweet I would strongly advise not doing
that because it's best doing it once you
have all the upgrades and like you oh
but you know if you want to do it there
like you know right at the beginning you
go ahead so they'll let you do it it's
nice that it's unlocked at the beginning
like just out the gate you don't have to
beat the game or anything oh look at me
Virgil you're insane
excellent oh boy oh I tell you how to
play the game oh you know I was gonna
try to figure it yeah I think I okay so
why is or your ranged attacks okay yeah
X is your melee suite and a jump your
your style
move okay lock on hold it I got to hold
it okay yeah sweet oh I'm ready
all right we're down to next what's like
okay
that's where it changes with every
controller you're basically like the
vanilla version right that's fine that's
I that's very representative of how I'm
going into this you got like nothing
nothing yep here we go guys wish me luck
let's do it great yeah just get my jump
hey my melee attack isn't working
Oh whoop okay for me it was X Oh
that's how I got to swing and just now
did I do that okay what's that one do do
I waste like energy doing so I see them
okay I should save those white okay
saundra holding it down I'm just kind of
following along alright I like that
lightning one over there come with it
woo got it a white orb okay cool
MP
whoa
oh I jumped by mr. Daaga how do i dodges
virgil okay there we go
just getting my buttons down folks
whoops don't want them to whack me again
there we go Oh
nice you got your your handguns whoa
what's that oh it's evil the right time
okay
there we go oh well I got dope come on
show yourself I can't walk on it's not
letting me because he's just a floating
thing there we go
dang it we have to have like our back
space to them watch oh you got your
projectile I got to figure out how to
use mine I forgot already
what did a little teleporting thing this
guy won't die show yourself
see there you go okay it has to be like
a projectile me
okay follow you put a green or help okay
good good let's go your mind
so these guys are brothers you say right
we even have the same white hair oh
shoot
oh I was juggling him got him where's
his health bar okay okay
I meant the enemy do they they don't
have one oh well I don't like that guy
chop them to bits oh we missed some orbs
no biggie
there they are all right which way shall
we go now we didn't do this one yet who
fire we okay sweet jump right in chat
how we doing
they added style switching that is
correct got him
oh you got to time everything yep I'm no
good at that either
oh man alright what's the style switch
button again so I can use a projectile
sweet also I can't defeat these guys out
of my own
okay
oh okay this is reject pile sweet lots I
learned here folks this is my very first
time
don't let their every use
they're basically the hardest weapon
these ones
oh nice I'm just punching the f out of
people
the taunting oh that's so funny you get
style points or like for part of your
grade at the end oh well actually that's
so funny
do I have unlimited a decent oh sweet
there's no ammo
oh I love that man it really is the
opposite of Resident Evil at least this
particular game oh you I got it's bad
alright didn't get it back dang dang it
there you go come to me and then also
under you can just blast them away hello
God and chat houses looking for you guys
so far this co-op mode look pretty dope
I'm having a great time
someone said that in China thought they
were trolling oh my god
is it like has anyone made it to the oh
my god it's not as daunting as it seems
actually I believe someone chat mention
did water oh that's what the is okay
what's the lightest one cuz I still I'm
still sort of warming up here water I
see good old water one let's go oh that
was sick
I'm just punching the F out of a spider
I keep doing that one move I don't mean
to where I'm doing like a jump flip I'm
doing like yeah like a somersault in the
air
whoops my bad there we go
Oh so you have directional moves no I
bought the amiibo and I was ready to
play it when it came out for the switch
never did I'm such a slacker I'm dead I
gotta wait okay Alessandra you've got
this he still works people chat is still
singing the phrases about the awesome
music
the decimation the chat says it's crazy
witnessing someone playing DMC for the
first time thankfully it's the best in
the series yep this is my first but we
have Alessandra who's played each and
every one I'm dead for sure you can
shoot them portals and get help that's
cool oh they were just shooting the
[ __ ] all right there you all right hey
I'm back
sweet okay Bob Jones says I need to
dodge okay I'm gonna work on that
because I just kind of learned how
breakdown what still blue come on Dario
just kick the [ __ ] out of them
oh yeah oops
you guys can obviously tell which one I
am I'm Virgil Oh still read got him who
I like the gauntlets but I like the
sword - I think I might stick with it
for a while
nice look at that that brother
Brotherhood nice right there
hundred floors okay
cyborg man you missed that we had the
the Dante pizza scene earlier oh sorry
scream into the mic there that was it
that was the floor oh my god chat I
don't know if I'm ready for this
use the devil trigger yep a devil
triggers your enhance states oh ok ok
this Wow I'm faster and we I still suck
at this game the Lycans oh it only
lasted for a second yeah I see
this is playing so smoothly
right yeah hey I read orbs yeah
Vivek asks when did they add co-op this
is for this we are playing the switch
port today which has co-op for bloody
palace so your look that's what you're
looking at friend right it went
backwards yeah no this is pretty much
the definitive yeah maybe worth the
rebuy there are more special features
added to this like changing of weapons
on the what is it not in this mode right
no yeah oh cool style style question
again the original game
[Music]
or there it is that little minis
brand-new friends yeah
ah Galvatron ask in the coop be played
online unfortunately no yeah am I the
little brother looking I'm so annoying
uh-huh
are there twins right so they were born
oh here we go
local call local co-op only yes that's
correct
oh yeah nice
Oh oh nice you're holding it you're
holding them down with your shots there
that's the same just nice Oh your your
guns are much cooler than my arrows
that's cool and that's right because you
told me like I'm going in as like a a
bare-bones version of Virgil so like I
have nothing no abilities or anything
yet I got enough and I'm having fun Oh
switch over to my gun are the other
sword and I'll try out the gauntlets
been in the chat you know being in a
two-on-one has online co-op but it's not
double make rocky adapting djenka not
a--not okay that's another series we
discussed that I have not been into so
who knows maybe I'll like that series
more I've seen all these cutscenes and
stuff it's just this over the top except
like you have you know it's not Dante oh
oh
it's like wizards chess I'll accept it
we're like in some other dimension yeah
onion
okay oh really
okay and here I was just trying to kill
everything I saw and it didn't work out
for me as you guys can see I died no
that's okay we just wanted to give a
little taste of how this mode works and
call up anyway yes this co-op is the
only on the switch version Hasaan
then then came back and said look I love
DMC but Bayonetta though you guys can
have this fight offline okay I'm just
kidding the mc5 or so huh
all right Alessandro TJ asks DMC 3 or 5
which has smooth or combat 5 I figured
cuz it's newer but had asked o Hasan
asks does the ps4 or Xbox get this co-op
update nah bro you gotta get the switch
only it's like the special edition that
came out for the switch and it was
surprising how much they added to it so
it is kind of a unique yet definitive
version according to our friend
Alessandro here CEO so you got this
you're not ending our Brotherhood yet
you lived it's gonna be dead I can't can
I just like fade away they just keep my
body there live come back here we go
I'll just from afar I'll just work on
these projectiles look man do I have I
don't have any other projectiles at the
moment huh oh well gauntlet so I'll go
back to this
you should with and everything oh man a
sound
oh god I got to take your advice when he
turns red just back away he's gonna
attack look
oh whoa whoa
got him
do they have plans to maybe add these
features to the feet to Xbox and ps4 I
mean we never thought we'd see this so
yeah who knows right
oh shoot the Grim Reaper I'm gonna stand
back here bite the little guys Rin sees
Castlevania it looks like member Dracula
and the very first Castlevania who
basically just looks like the Grim
Reaper whoa hey
I haven't noticed my own I should react
is there a block or you just dodged
everybody okay cool ah what is your the
cooler brother
here we go
ah
right there
he's gone nice work ooh I keep missing
these
oh I'm not locked on Wow bro at least I
knew its how to correct the situation
who don't we green ones we need those
man you want to go for another hundred
this is for you chat I'm so glad
Alessandro is here there we go that one
yeah sorry I keep forgetting to lock on
there we're over Heidi oh crap
oh yeah okay let's go ah so so
short-lived oh we got one freaking
doesn't get old sorry okay
and another one showed up I wonder if we
have to kill him in a certain time limit
before another one appears otherwise
it'll just endlessly do this we're
moving there we go okay jump attack that
was all you dude I'm just happy to be
here folks oh my god here we go
what floor are we on level let's set it
on the bottom ooh
scared I don't know what to do first
this seems to be working
ooh there we go
I cornered one of them ah now I'm locked
onto the wrong one
oh it's got just showed up
whoa
how far have you made it in this
gauntlet mode have you ever made it to
nine what is it no
oh wow
but that doesn't make it any easier so
still very different there's a lot less
levels of difficulty another hundred
let's go BBS asks wasn't gesture a
Boston book 20 times
okay you the character
uh funds have been a treat yeah like one
of the more weird bosses yeah like it
it's not very difficult you set this or
like figure out
I see oh my gosh another hundred oh my
gosh
no thanks to me by the way
[Laughter]
I like I like this projectile shot
helpful whoa
one more
nice that was a nice easy one there
they're telling me to use a DT again TT
yeah all right I will next one cool okay
where's all these purple things suck
okay I'll use it on this look Oh
there we go that was for you chat line
42 I guess right we hate these things
there we go k not so mad okay who
song I can finally hear it the combat is
so loud I barely hear them easier got
them
another hundred man who who has done the
grind like level / level you know not
using the fire portals like what you
said the water ones are just one level
up who's done that from 0 to 9999 just
using water are these guys paint making
shooting them from here
oh cool oh yeah you told me that earlier
nice
here we go yeah
ohyou
nuts
there we go teamwork getting a little
better right does the camera feel wonky
trying to compensate for both lock on
little bit right if we're too far from
each other yeah I would say nothing
major not game breaking binomials but
it's there I got keep blocking there we
go switch it up change my weapon here
whoa I'm right in the middle of this to
back up nice like some levels are a lot
shorter yeah and Gauntlet pretty cool
mixes it up at least chat says yep dmc3
still holds up glad you're having a good
time watching you want this is available
on the switch for leave $19.99 maybe
don't quote me on that but it's
available as of yesterday this co-op
mode is exclusive to this version
tourim of whoo well we got about 15
minutes left maybe after this match all
asunder we can get back to the story so
to show off like I don't know actually
you can do all the features within this
mode like style switching and weapons
swapping okay well chat let us know we
got 15 minutes left one see more of this
or you want to go back to the story a
little bit
Alessandra knows what's up you can
navigate us through but I am here as
Virgil this is this lift up win for you
whoa oh oh here they shrunk it back down
to 4/3 again that's ok
oh okay oh shoot my health is low can I
do that cool mode yeah does the does the
help I regenerate is it based off the
damage I do in that mode or like just
give me help I didn't do much this time
myself low health whoa I'm just keeping
my distance y'all I have low health whoa
this is cool though
I like this boss idea Oh
back it up ah man I tried to dodge
yeah the split-screen though right Bob
Jones I tried now I'm down there you got
this all Sandro oh that's no fair cuz
you but you do have a block I don't well
you know that wasn't a bad attempt for
my very first time nice how many boss
like when does a boss show up every
thousand levels or so okay like
especially considering that there's
co-op yeah that's all new to this
version I see I see that wasn't bad in
the main story do you get to play as
Virgil for a little bit mm-hmm
well Virgil actually has his own like
come likes and stand alone like campaign
as well so within this game yep sweet
but also there's the added this Easter
Egg where sort of during a particular
fight like both characters were together
and if there's a second controller like
oh cool only during that one boss battle
that's cool this is a very sick how we
just played right now it's like everyone
they just share a screen like cool
awesome
was that on the original version oh
that's so cool but yeah they never like
it was never like stated outright sure
yeah you had to find it yeah sure yeah
I'll keep up with the chat here let's
see Xena's Esha we've got another 10
minutes well 12 minutes let me find a
quick mission for us to do ah xanadus
wants to place with his brother and now
it's time he said he says now it's time
to give him a call with the good news
yeah man this is it for the switch there
I am
Virgil that's me um
who's that guy oh that was another
character named Arkham Oh was he in the
beginning yes who okay the guy he was
the guy ruined my pizza shops rudely
interrupted all right so yeah this is
like one of the more like puzzling
sections of the game were you you're
basically going through this environment
you have to explore okay figure out
where to go next
it's a really cool looking you like a
broken temple yeah Doublemint cry is
very distinct like sort of like sense of
style that sort of blends like sort of
modern like you know sort of like sort
of like machismo like Chunin like style
like you know the more like a sort of
Eastern European like you know yeah I
heard they took the influence from you
know specifically the part in Resident
Evil for when you go to the temple and
that was kind of like how this was
formed like something along those lines
correct me if I'm wrong chatty - nice oh
my god
60 FPS oh yeah baby
for the swim I'm at a split screen balls
fight right oh yeah was noticeably well
it chug not chug it would just drop to
30 instead it
oh yeah being flash by in flash 60fps I
love to see down the switch for some
reason I'm always like oh the switch
can't pull it off
I'm always so wrong about that
especially docked right again another
incredible port and actually had a
recent really
Wow I didn't see that coming sorry there
we go see
Strax and the chat says this resident
evil' puzzle as puzzles section of the
game but with more action I mean it's
all action in this game y'all know
although you were saying to had some
puzzling elements or was that one the
very first one no the one okay and
according to chat and you I could just
skip part two it's not full we'll just
forget it existed five though around
I remember when around the office when
the five came out everyone was singing
its praises I might jump into five first
said that like ten times well I think
it's time great game so you said they'd
be
you'd be surprised if four was ported to
the switch yeah I mean it seems a lot
more us a lot less dated
I would love to see it but I'm wondering
if they do this which is capable yeah it
was a ps3 game not ps2 game needs to run
at 60fps
oh man that might be a tall order if it
doesn't I mean I can understand The
Witcher you know making it like because
it's a big game but uh you know it
doesn't need to be like it 60fps or
anything right it's totally playable
thirty but to play it to really
appreciate is to play it like plants
like responsive
yeah mama it's very much the fighting
game it's slower the street fighters of
the action go
okay so 60 no less
so this for anyone tuning in a little we
are wrapping it up here soon but this
version of double my cart Devil May Cry
3 has been ported to the switch it just
launched yesterday it's got a bunch of
switch exclusive features Alejandro is
showing them off here there are there's
easy weapon swapping for more than just
two weapons we got a whole weapon wheel
there's a style switcher which you can
switch on the fly there now he's a
gunslinger out of nowhere just like that
what you have to do normally like press
pause and navigate through the menus ok
this this is really it this is the whole
definitive version if you want to try at
least get one good yeah go for a man oh
we got Evan Langer in the chat chatting
you are a cheering you on he says heck
yeah good to see Alessandra on the
stream kicking ass and taking names
Thanks yeah ooh Dean says Ninja Gaiden
black for the switch would be sick on
this that'd be great them that's
actually an amazing action it still
holds up really well do you need to get
backwards compatibility with the Xbox
one access correct that's so sick it
still holds up really well yeah that's
good to hear but yeah port on this would
be welcome of course
DBS says blue orb up
oh no extract says the reboot of the
original DMC got a lot of criticism
because it launched at 30fps no but uh I
feel like that the combat system they
made actually pretty well but also I
played the game on PC so
none of that yeah but even in the
definitive edition
nice Strax thanks for joining us today
he says he's got to go but he's glad we
showcased the game thanks for joining us
bench TV salute me please just give you
one of these
that's for you man that's what you want
oh my god these those creatures are ugly
but they're like they have like this
mold on them that like grows what was it
you want to do a special block that was
a perfect parry when you pull up a parry
you'll basically charge up energy which
you can immediately fire back sick I saw
you I did see you push him away as soon
as you did that so nice but it sounds
like it was hard to do like you just
have to time that yeah I keep it's
basically like third strike okay yeah I
was never into that I yeah now because
it's not good I like third strike just
to play casually but like I competitive
year away never whoa
this thing is just minding its own
business up Zenna session the chat says
perry god whoo yep his name is Cassandra
we had to do it though
Brandin Hernandez will see you tomorrow
man for Community Friday that's right
thanks for joining us today though dude
always good to have you here
reshooting oh it's up there uh this dude
is just living at home and you come here
and just destroy him
he made this castle his home bench says
Devil May Cry 5 not for the switch not
yet DVS yes this is the worm boss gross
you got this dog Sancho
then as ishes dmc3 perry's will never
stop being sick which is true but did
they like stop the parrying system that
was cool
oh good here they didn't like remove it
was it introduced in three DBS GBS is
here with the pro strats you like hit it
on the head I don't know Alessandra I
trust your instincts - I think Chavez is
trying to kind of help where they can
the box is massive
hey tails blowing joke the meter goes
down if you don't hit her mom I see
something a human screaming almost grows
what's your favorite mode to be as far
as like styles up there on the top left
swordmaster
nice I dabble that's the Dodge one
yeah
oh those are the ice with nunchucks you
got earlier sick
Oh
like how this guy doesn't like outwardly
attacking he's just going in and out of
these Pope's kind of like that one
bought remember in Super Mario 64 that
big worm guy although he tries to bite
you
dead Bart says they officially added
style switcher on the switch yes my
friend that's why we are playing today
that is one of many switch exclusive
features that was been ported to the
Devil May Cry 3 version way actually all
hundred has style switching been
introduced in any other game are like it
was in later editions like Devil May Cry
5 is that what you're saying okay oh
that's so cool yep but they brought it
back to three that's what you're seeing
here today oh no you look like just a
bullet sponge and sheet what's happening
items yes amen they're cheating if
they're made available to you like that
jump on it and hit from above okay there
we go oh shoot you riding this thing oh
look at that
Oh sick hey you made quick work of that
towards the end there see Bob Jones
that's what I was saying seems like the
worm is minding his own business and
you're ruining it steady I was like yeah
he lives here he made a nice nest out of
the castle but uh Dante just said f all
well you know what that's a good place
to wrap it up that was perfect that's
the end of the boss fight let's switch
back to this over here let me see if I
can get this going nicely done okay
let's get the ranking first
Alessandro killed it nice hey man he is
probably way better than I could do so
thank you guys we'll end it there ah
thank you for joining us today
Alessandro it was great having you on
man he knows what he's doing and he's
kind of warming me up to the idea of
getting into DMC I have not played so
we're so glad you're here today thank
you for joining us today
gamespot live yeah of course gamespot
live is live every weekday at 11 a.m.
tomorrow we have community Fridays so
join us back then or join us tomorrow I
should say and we'll see you then you
guys have a good day have a good day
thanks bye